[Music]
hi everyone and welcome my name is Colby
Hawker and I'm product manager for
Google Cloud natural language Ai and I'm
joined today by Eric bursch senior vice
president of USA Today parent company
Gannett today I'll be talking about how
to maximize content relevance with large
language models
first I'm going to cover how natural
language processing can improve content
personalization and filtering I'll talk
about how we can gain understanding with
a new era of language models then we'll
talk about Google's natural language Ai
and finally we'll jump into some real
industry applications and use cases and
we'll hear from Eric about how Google's
natural language AI is used across the
USA Today Network newsrooms
so let's start with a bridge between
natural language processing and
personalization
modern organizations from digital media
and news aggregators to ad platforms
require some type of personalization to
deliver relevant content and in order to
deliver the best content understanding
must come first this content could be a
web page an audio transcription or a
social Media Forum
the big problem is that machines have
always struggled with natural language
with advances in technology there has
always been this major gap between
people and computers
the reason is that text is ambiguous
it's unstructured its meaning is
dictated by context positioning and
evolving connotations
take a one word example server the
meaning can be very different across
different scenarios server can have a
check is very different than the server
when the point you have to look Beyond
specific terms to get the real meaning
this is a daunting challenge that Google
faces every day with billions of daily
search queries and a good fraction of
these queries are brand new and have
never been seen by Google before
so we need a language model
a language model learns to make
predictions on text input based on
patterns it has been exposed to it
learns from lots and lots of examples
generated by real people
the outcome should mirror natural
language and give us some information
whether that be some sort of text output
or a signal that can be used and give us
some sort of insight
deep learning has given us richer
content comprehension and in the case of
Google search there was a big
breakthrough with a type of model called
the Transformer this represented one of
the biggest leaps forward in the history
of search
and it so happens that the technology
that helps search understand user
queries can also help media-rich
organizations understand their content
for advertising organizations need
Precision targeting to associate ads
with a narrower user profile and for
Content Discovery recommendation models
and content filters are key and given
the massive amount of content generated
every day it's imperative to identify
the most relevant Trends in news stories
and articles
so I'll talk a little bit now about how
we can gain critical understanding
through new advancements in language
modeling
a large language model is what you get
when you have a highly scalable
Transformer model
and then you add significantly more data
and more parameters to compute
and when I say more I mean orders of
magnitude larger than standard models
think of tens of billions of parameters
in this scale unlocks new capabilities
there are three advantages I'll
highlight
one transferable learnings across tasks
and languages for high flexibility
two the model captures unique and
evolving connotations with significantly
more data
and three enhanced ability to understand
the contextual meaning
so first one General model can transfer
its knowledge across specific language
tasks
in the Deep pre-trained knowledge can
also be used as a base to cater to
specialized domains you provide just a
few samples and the model will be
upskilled for say something like sports
or make predictions on Sports data in
other words we can fine tune for
specialized classification while
retaining its prior knowledge
secondly linguistic connotations are
learned from massive amounts of natural
language in the data it's exposed to as
you can see in the sample of neural
embeddings the idea is to measure
similarity to better informed
predictions the more representation we
get the more performant
lastly the model can make better
predictions about word references in
context as a simple example what does it
refer to it is learn which words to
attend to
in order to understand its meaning
and with these advantages large language
models or loms can provide Rich
understanding of language and that's
really helpful especially when it comes
to granular insights that are required
for a downstream personalization
you'll notice in this particular example
there's no explicit reference to clean
or environmentally friendly but it was
able to gather enough information to
make a good prediction
now let's talk about the Google Cloud
natural language API
Google cloud is pleased to announce a
new content classification model that
incorporates the best of Google to give
customers better predictions on
text-based content
this release is a first step towards
bringing the power of large language
models to our customers for a popular
use case
with this latest release developers and
practitioners can expect better insights
better ad targeting and better
recommendations for their users with
Google Cloud natural language developers
now have access to Best in Class
language Transformer with a distilled
knowledge of the World Wide Web and so
what makes Google's new content
classifications so unique specifically
well first it's incredibly expansive now
supporting over a hundred different
categories
second it's highly scalable across
content types and languages you can
point to HTML or raw text process Bowl
short form and long form content and
there's multilingual support for 11
languages
finally it's trained on a massive amount
of web data at Google scale
as an example
you can segment and classify short text
transcriptions with just a few lines of
code
this is especially useful for podcasts
or online forums we could take a
transcribe Financial podcast and
delineate between investing in
Commodities and Futures and say
investing in currencies and even if the
conversation is muddied with side
conversation you can still understand
what was actually intended
in another example you can point to a
URL of a long online news article
without the pre-processing
and you'll get a reliable signal to
match users with relevant content
this longer article is about skin care
but it's littered with keywords like
caffeine in a traditional model
misclassified this article as a beverage
but the natural language API could make
an accurate prediction with confidence
and that's Mission critical because the
signal will now be used for
content-based filtering or a more
sophisticated recommendation engine and
to determine the content that is shown
to users so it's important that we get
this right
with Google Cloud's natural language API
you can now get even more insight with
less input and it's easy to use for
critical Downstream tasks
now I'll turn the time over to Eric who
will speak briefly about how USA Today
is using the cloud natural language API
for Content targeting and other
relevance driven workflows over to you
Eric
Colby thank you for the introduction and
excited to to join the conversation uh
just a little bit about my role of
Gannett I'm responsible for digital
consumer product and Engineering inside
of our ganet media organization uh I
thought it'd be worthwhile to touch a
little bit on on ganet in USA Today
um you know Gannett is the parent
company of USA Today obviously our
national brand very recognizable from
the digital and print perspective
um you know in alignment with our
national brand we have over 300 local
properties uh that uh some of those are
very recognizable such as Detroit Free
Press Arizona Republic
um Indianapolis Star et cetera
um and with that national and local mix
we really feel like it's extremely
strong
um strong play for organette and and
makes up the USA Today Network
um one thing I'd like to talk about with
with U.S Senate network is is the scale
um we every month we have over 160
million unique visitors that uh that
visit our products our digital products
across the use of the network so quite a
large scale from that perspective and
then as we talk about content
classification another scale that's
that's extremely important is how many
articles we publish a day we published
about 2 000 articles a day and that's
probably on the low end uh across our
U.S Senate Network so it was very
important for us to align with a partner
that could handle that type of scale uh
when we're talking about content
classification and you know when we
you'll know a couple words that I I talk
about here uh you know it's consistent
reliable et cetera but the ability to
drive consistent reliable cost
classifications at their skill is is the
first and foremost uh piece that we
wanted with a partner we had other
Solutions in the past
um that required a lot more resource
effort on our side to to drive uh that
consistency and it didn't it didn't
match what we're getting from the NL API
um is provided to us now so it's been a
big win from that perspective
um you know there is a revenue side to
uh us doing content classifications
um and that has been a dramatic game
changer for our sales organization we
heavily Drive campaigns with different
classifications
um you know and that's really given our
sales teams a a different side of a
conversation to bring to uh to Partners
on their side we had this to a certain
degree again in our old uh our old
solution but we've gone to a completely
different level because of the
classifications
um with NL API
um I think in this day and age there
there is a lot of heavy news out there
um you know with everything going on
nationally in the world
um and what we've done from a sentiment
analysis standpoint with NL API has
really allowed us to open up uh
different product conversations and
again different Revenue conversations
um and really what we've done is we've
targeted
um you know good or happy or lighter
news as you might think about it um as
and we've been presenting that through a
product perspective we've also
um had ad campaigns and partners that
have wanted to associate themselves with
you know with that with that type of
content and it's it's been a uh you know
big big bump for us from a sentiment
analysis standpoint
um you know the last thing I'll say is
is you know to to be able to understand
the consumption pattern uh insights
you'll need a solution that's that's
extremely reliable and if you say that
you know several times you know the
standardized nature uh of the
classification vocabulary is a key to to
all that we do from that standpoint uh
because of small changes relatively
slowly
um we can base all sorts of pattern
decisions on those results which have
has has brought new product ideas to the
table some of the specific products that
we've rolled rolled out recently
um you heard mentioned Colby talking
about personalization earlier in the
deck but this is this has enabled us to
really expand out our level of
personalization to our users of the U.S
event Network through different products
and our ability to align content
classifications with with their
consumption patterns and bring content
throughout the USDA Network to the
Forefront for them has been a a big one
for our users
I think secondly the other product
enhancement that we've been able to push
forward with is the ability to automate
you know an audience facing the front or
story page to our users without having
our editorial team have to manage that
and that was a result of our content
classification consistency and having a
high degree of confidence that what we
were presented through that automated
front to the user
um you know really was was the correct
content that we wanted
so as I transition from that into uh you
into the relationship that we've had
with with Google I first want to tip my
cap to to Lou Schilling who is
internally again been our champion for
for this product from this integration
um Lou has a couple quotes here I'm I'm
not going to read the quotes you guys
can follow up on those uh he's done a
fabulous job on our side working with
the Google team uh the second you know
area I'll tip my hat to the Google API
team you know we've asked a lot of them
we've asked a lot of uh you know
enhancements uh you know as we've as
we've gotten deep into the API
um it's been a great relationship so far
and I really appreciate the effort that
they've put in uh from their side so
Colby thank you very much for uh for
having me
thanks Eric we're certainly glad you
were able to find uh value in Google
cloud and thanks everyone uh who is
viewing live
um you can find more information about
Google Cloud natural language as well as
the content classification update on our
website thanks Eric and thanks again for
everyone who's watching and we wish you
all the best until next time
[Music]